first we want to bring you up to speed
on what's happening here in Washington
the crack political team over at the
Washington Post our daily local
newspaper has uncovered a brand new
species of fake news they think you need
to know about imaginary left-wing mobs
in a piece posted last night the post
explained that in order to win the
midterm elections those Republicans have
quote casts the Trump resistance
movement as an angry mob now cast is of
course here a synonym for misrepresented
the Washington Post wants you to know
that these mobs are not real they're an
elysian and that may surprise you
because you may have recently seen
videos of prominent Republicans being
chased out of restaurants by screaming
progressives you may have read news
accounts about how a Republican
congressman from Louisiana was shot with
a high-powered rifle by a Bernie Sanders
supporter you may have seen college
campuses descend into writing simply
because conservatives showed up to talk
and just this past weekend you may have
watched transfixed as groups of
hysterical young people yelled at
Republican lawmakers in Capitol Hill and
then pounded and raged on the front
doors of the Supreme Court all of this
may have given you the mistaken
impression that there is a threat of
disorder and lawlessness from the left
building in this country some of it
funded by a man that the Washington Post
neutrally describes them according now
as philanthropist George Soros well rest
easy says the post in fact all of this
talk of left-wing mobs quote taps
grievances about the nation's
fast-moving cultural and demographic
shifts in other words this is racism and
it's design says the post quote for the
benefit of white voters particularly men
Wow
so the angry left-wing mobs you thought
you had been watching on television turn
out to be merely a hallucination they're
a fever dream concocted by those
diabolical magicians over it Fox News
thank heaven you can wake up now none of
it is real it's 1996 again but wait has
anyone told the angry left-wing mobs
about this they seem to believe that
they exist in Portland they're still
blocking
traffic and breaking things and
screaming at old ladies in wheelchairs
apparently they don't get the Washington
Post in Oregon watch don't believe your
lying eyes now some reports there
haven't been many reports but some
describe the protesters you just watch
as in Tifa others say their black lives
matter it doesn't matter what you're
actually looking at is the youth wing of
the Democratic Party these are their
shock troops listen to Maxine Waters and
Cory Booker call them to arms go to the
hill today get up and please get up in
the face of some Congress people
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
go get them get in their face
well they obeyed the left always obeys
obedience is the whole point of their
program well thanks to incidents like
the one you just saw the ones the
Washington Post assures you aren't real
didn't really happen and you have no
right to be worried about normal people
across the country nevertheless are
becoming concerned now that's racist
says the post because of course being
yelled at by rich white kids and not
liking it is racist but nevertheless
kelly paul senator of wife of Senator
Rand Paul says that she's so concerned
by what's happening that she keeps a
loaded gun by her bed watch so many
frankly unhinged people and unstable
people out there and when they hear
someone on their side telling them get
up in their face they take that
literally and they think that that gives
them a license to be very aggressive be
harassing it does scare me
that there is going to be somebody that
is really unstable that takes that
message a step further we've updated all
of our security systems at home we I
sleep with a loaded gun by my bed I've
always felt very safe used to never even
lock our doors and and now that is all
changed
well the Washington Post might call mrs.
Paul paranoid on the other hand many on
the Left openly celebrated when her
husband went up in the hospital after
being assaulted by an angry liberal my
husband had six broken ribs and was
violently assaulted was seriously
seriously injured and to have people
like cher and Bette Midler laughing on
the internet and lauding his attacker
it's like well what kind of person are
you that you think that is
octuple well that's a fair question in
the video we just showed you is real
video we didn't make it up in the
basement to scare you or to win a
midterms assessing everything you've
seen over the past year you might be
tempted to conclude that just maybe
there is a growing problem with
left-wing mob violence but left-wing
leaders and their propagandists in the
press have concluded you'll be surprised
to learn the exact opposite faced with
one left-wing riot after another they
have decided the problem is actually you
you're the problem sitting at home
you're dangerous in the New York Times
this morning Paul Krugman accused the
Republican Party of harboring
authoritarian impulses apparently
Republicans have been chasing prominent
Democrats out of restaurants recently
and banging on cars oh wait there's that
projection thing again Hillary Clinton
is so worried though about how dangerous
the Republican Party has become those
angry Mormon grandmothers and black
bandanas you're seeing in downtown
Portland smashing windows that she no
longer considers Republicans Americans
or even fully human
according to Hillary Clinton you no
longer have to be civil to Republicans
you can do whatever you want to them
because they deserve it you cannot be
civil with a political party that wants
to destroy what you stand for what you
care about that's why I believe if we
are fortunate enough to win back the
house and/or the Senate that's when
civility can start again yeah when we
win civility can return so there you
have it the perfect distillation there's
the most recent Democratic presidential
candidate the leader of her party by
default endorsing viciousness openly
against her political opponents and yet
according to The Washington Post a
newspaper this is what Republican
extremism looks like and you'd have to
be crazy not to see it